[Musica]
buonasera tutte a tutti grazie per
essere qui in presenza indiretta e il
countdown il countdown che riguarda un
po all'urgenza l'emergenza che tutti
affrontiamo perché qualcuno come me come
altre centinaia di migliaia di persone
come me che sono innamorate della natura
innamorate degli animali che magari sono
partite tantissimi anni fa con un sogno
molto semplice salvare il panda un sogno
inquietante della mia generazione sono
certa che si riconosceranno perché oggi
ci troviamo a discutere di altro perché
parliamo di cannuccia di plastica perché
parliamo di pesticidi perché parliamo
dell'emergenza climatica perché tutto è
connesso perché noi siamo natura perché
i problemi hanno avuto un'evoluzione che
qualcuno aveva previsto ma che
effettivamente avuto un'accelerazione
incredibile e perché effettivamente
abbiamo in mano delle soluzioni che è
necessario più che mai accelerare a loro
volta e questo è quello che oggi vorrei
raccontarle che si racchiude in questa
fase che per me rappresenta un po
l'essenza del motivo per cui pur avendo
il desiderio la speranza di potermi
sempre più dedicare a quella che è
appunto la la passione per la natura in
senso stretto ritengo oggi importante e
urgente che tutti i dedichino un po del
loro tempo invece a percorrere quelle
soluzioni che effettivamente abbiamo
trovato così che non solo possiamo
garantire di salvare tutto quello che
già siamo riusciti in qualche modo a
mettere da parte quindi specie iconiche
che tutti sicuramente conoscete die
panne dalle tigri e leopardi agli orsi
polari e che in qualche modo grazie a
decenni di azione effettivamente oggi
hanno una speranza e una prospettiva che
50 anni fa non avrebbero avuto ma tutto
questo non è più sufficiente
partiamo sempre da gli animali per
spiegare qual è il problema
il problema è che mentre ci dedicavamo
giustamente a cercare di salvare alcune
aree del pianeta e alcune specie del
pianeta intanto noi esseri umani
trasformavano il mondo e ve lo racconto
in questo modo trasforma il mondo cosa
significa che oggi nel modo in cui
viviamo oggi questi sono dati di subito
prima della pandemia il 70 per cento di
tutti gli uccelli presenti il mondo sono
pollame il pollame sono sappiamo tutti
uccelli dedicati fondamentalmente al
nostro sostentamento quindi animali che
esistono in funzione dell'essere umano
i mammiferi cosa sappiamo dei mammiferi
che sono gli animali verso cui ci
sentiamo spesso più vicini tutti abbiamo
grande empatia per i mammiferi
l'immaginiamo liberi felici li
immaginiamo tanti i mammiferi il 60 per
cento dei mammiferi sono animali da
allevamento bovini principalmente ma non
solo ben il 36 per cento dei mammiferi
del mondo siamo noi un terzo di tutti i
mammiferi del mondo sono essere umani è
un numero inquietante un 1 che ha colto
di sorpresa anche alcuni degli addetti
di essere al settore e quindi quegli
animali che noi tendenzialmente
immaginiamo quando sogniamo appunto
scenari di natura quegli animali un po
elusivi molto spesso bellissimi che ci
ci affascinano così tanto grado mandiamo
i documentari sono solo il 4 per cento
cosa è successo quindi non soltanto noi
siamo in un epoca che giustamente è
stata definita l'epoca della sesta
estinzione di massa perché sappiamo oggi
che circa un milione di specie in tutto
il mondo sono minacciate da estinzione
ma di fatto sta avvenendo per la nostra
opera non per nostra volontà in un certo
senso ma di fatto ne siamo un'unica
causa una sostituzione della
biodiversità presente su questo pianeta
questa questa cosa è legata a un
fenomeno molto chiaro e investe tutti i
livelli della biodiversità quella delle
piante quella degli animali fino al con
gli insetti che come ormai tutti sanno
sono gli animali sono tra le specie più
presenti più numerose in tutto il
pianeta ma che uno studio recente ha
dimostrato che per la maggior parte
delle specie diminuiscono tra 1 e 2 per
cento all'anno per ogni specie può
sembrare un numero molto piccolo ma
anche solo sono moltiplicate per dieci
anni rendete conto che significa che
alcune specie in realtà hanno pochi
decenni di vita davanti a loro se
qualcosa non cambia
come è stato possibile questo è perché
questo è avvenuto fondamentalmente sotto
i nostri occhi senza che nessuno per
tanto tempo se ne accorgesse è successa
una cosa molto simile a quella che
succede purtroppo in questi giorni in
questi mesi con la pandemia che tutti
conosciamo
a volte alcune curve hanno una crescita
esponenziale
vuol dire che da un certo punto in poi
improvvisamente l'accelerazione diventa
molto forte per quanto riguarda la
pandemia come tutti sappiamo c'è un
andamento che prevede che
nel giro di pochissime settimane i
numeri si moltiplicano alla velocità
spaventosa per quanto riguarda la
perdita di biodiversità del pianeta è
successo fondamentalmente lo stesso
fenomeno ma spalmato su una misura di
tempo di alcuni decenni che ha la mente
umana sembra un tempo lunghissimo non è
un'emergenza non è una cosa che succede
domani non è una cosa che mi mette a
rischio domani quindi in fondo mele
potrà occupare
e invece no e invece no perché di fatto
siamo scivolati senza rendercene conto
in un epoca che oggi viene chiamata
antropocene e rispetto alla quale
fondamentalmente non abbiamo più
soluzioni se non un inversione drastica
urgente e immediata della direzione che
abbiamo preso perché questa urgenza
perché di fatto negli anni passati sono
stati identificati quelli che sono i
limiti del pianeta giustamente viviamo
in un sistema finito lo sappiamo tutti
ma ci sono scienziati che hanno dedicato
anni il tempo per identificare almeno
nove cosiddetti planetary boundaries
ovvero aree rispetto alle quali la
trasformazione di queste aree non deve
andare al di sopra di un certo confine
altrimenti di fatto la trasformazione
diventa irreversibile
non solo la trasformazione comincia ad
impattare anche tutte le altre aree e di
conseguenza la vita sul pianeta ci sono
almeno due di questi confini planetari
rispetto ai quasi noi siamo già andati
oltre uno riguarda per l'appunto la
biodiversità genetica perché la
riduzione della diversità genetica in
particolare per alcune aree per alcune
specie di fatto è già un fenomeno
irreversibile
in secondo luogo ci sono alcuni cicli
biogeochimici del pianeta su cui stiamo
influendo in maniera irreversibile per
esempio quello dell'azoto ma ce ne sono
altri che sono molto vicini a un punto
di non ritorno
uno fra tutti che tutti conoscete
benissimo perché oggetto di dibattito
quotidiano quello del cambiamento
climatico
il cambiamento climatico è stato in
questa in quest'epoca in questi ultimi
anni il grande protagonista della
dell'allarme dell'emergenza il
cambiamento climatico è stato l'oggetto
della prima manifestazione globale di
massa non era mai successo nella storia
dell'umanità che ci fosse un movimento
globale che si muovesse tutti insieme
allo stesso momento non solo un
movimento globale di giovani e
giovanissimi è evidente da un certo il
punto di vista che questo è stato
possibile perché oggi ci sono tecnologie
che fino a pochi anni fa non c'erano e
che hanno permesso una velocità di
diffusione di un certo tipo di
informazione di un certo tipo di
iniziativa ma è altrettanto evidente che
cos'altro avrebbe avuto smuovere come un
sol uomo centinaia di migliaia e milioni
di persone in tutto il pianeta se non
quello che ci riguarda tutti ovvero la
salute del nostro pianeta
una cosa importante da ricordare però è
che quello che sta succedendo oggi in
qualche modo era stato predetto predetto
è previsto con devo dire inquietanti
accuratezza già molti anni fa
c'è un testo che sono certa che
conosceranno dell'eni stupro che risale
a ben 50 anni fa ovvero tra pochissimi
mesi saranno 50 anni che questo testo è
stato pubblicato è di un gruppo di
ricercatori di studiosi di scienziati
del club di roma chiamato così perché
tra suoi fondatori dei suoi primi
promotori c'era anche un italiano ora
gli operai questo testo è interessante
notare come per molti anni sia stato
tradotto in italiano in maniera errata
come i limiti della cre del dello
sviluppo laddove invece l'ucla
traduzione corretta ai limiti della
crescita quello che si contesta oggi
quello che dobbiamo comprendere
l'oggetto delle nostre riflessioni nel
contesto della congiuntura in cui ci
troviamo infatti deve essere non tanto e
non solo il fatto che non possiamo più
svilupparci lo sviluppo di per sé è una
cosa sempre positiva un miglioramento ma
questo miglioramento deve coincidere con
una crescita continua e costante
la risposta è no ma non è quello che sta
succedendo quello che succede oggi
infatti è che noi ci troviamo con una
serie di ecosistemi che ci circondano e
che di fatto rendono tutto la possibile
la nostra vita quelli marini quelli
terrestri le acque dolci su cui
influiscono impattano in maniera
quotidiana e potentissima una serie di
processi che noi mettiamo in atto come
società e come esseri umani si va
ovviamente dal sovrasfruttamento del
suolo che tendenzialmente è un fenomeno
ampiamente sottovalutato ma che continua
ad essere a tutt'oggi una delle più
grandi cause di conflitto a livello
globale peraltro e c'è il
sovrasfruttamento delle specie pensate
per esempio alla pesca di cui si è
cominciato a parlare da poco ma di fatto
se ne è cominciato a parlare quando per
alcune specie e soprattutto in alcuni
mari tra cui il nostro mediterraneo con
mare chiuso è già quasi troppo tardi ci
sono poi le specie aliene che a causa
dell essere umano si spostano da una
zona all'altra
del controllo è un certo punto diventano
un problema che non sappiamo più come
gestire c'è l'inquinamento la plastica
oggi è la grande protagonista di questo
dibattito ma come sappiamo benissimo
l'inquinamento del terreno
l'inquinamento dell'aria produce dei
danni sulla salute umana e sulla salute
animale
quantificabili in milioni miliardi e in
tantissimo tempo in tantissime vite e
infine c'è il cambiamento climatico che
in qualche modo a tutti questi
cambiamenti precedenti è legato perché
ne sia conseguenza sia causa
cosa significa quindi viviamo in un
mondo progressivamente sempre più
diverso da quello che abbiamo trovato
significa che siamo diventati in grado
di vivere senza tutto quello che la
natura ci offre
assolutamente no ovviamente la natura
continua ad essere la fonte del nostro
sostentamento continua ad essere la
fonte di tutta la nostra ricerca
pensiamo per esempio alla ricerca medica
continua ad essere una fonte di
ispirazione per tutta una serie di
innovazioni a partire dalle innovazioni
tecnologiche continua a essere alla base
imprescindibile le nostre sistemi
alimentari tutti quanti sappiamo delle
emergenze degli impollinatori perché da
una parte perché indubbiamente le api
sono un meraviglioso essere che si
presta la simpatia popolare dall'altra
perché tutti sono interessati a capire
cosa e come arriva nel proprio piatto e
cosa rischiano di perdere se sparisce
che all'origine di questo qualcosa
la natura non è solo questo la natura è
anche la fonte di tantissime ispirazione
per tutto quello che riguarda la nostra
arte la nostra cultura e per quello più
che mai che riguarda il nostro benessere
psico fisico sempre più studi da
tantissimi anni dimostrano che il
passare del tempo in natura in qualche
modo
alleggerisce tantissimo le nostre stress
le nostre pressioni in particolare
quando sia bambini ma non solo
qual è quindi la soluzione c'è una
soluzione cosa possiamo fare e qua mi
concentro oggi qui noi in italia qual è
la strada che si può percorrere quali
sono le azioni quotidiane in qualche
modo che possono incastrarsi per
invertire un po questo flusso in cui
siamo immersi innanzi tutto c'è una
visione alla base di tutto questo credo
che molti conoscano gli obiettivi di
sviluppo del milan 30 gli abusi alti gis
penso che quasi tutti siete abituati a
vederli inseriti in uno schema in cui
questi cubetti colorati in qualche modo
rappresentano i diversi obiettivi a cui
si aspira fino al 2015 per arrivare al
2030 per avere un mondo più eco più
sostenibile più inclusivo ecco
l'immagine che vedete è un'immagine che
secondo me rappresenta quella che
dovrebbe essere la visione del mondo del
futuro perché non da una priorità ma da
un ordine logico
all'interno degli obiettivi del
millennio infatti ce ne sono alcuni che
vengono necessariamente logicamente
prima degli altri e in particolare tutti
quelli che riguardano la dimensione
ambientale quindi la biosfera la
biosfera terrestre quella marina il
cambiamento climatico la biodiversità
questi sono i fondamenti sui quali è
possibile costruire il raggiungimento
degli altri obiettivi quelli che
riguardano la sfera sociale e poi la
sfera economica non vi può essere
società ed economia sana al di fuori di
un ambiente che non sia altrettanto sano
questa deve essere veramente la visione
alla base di tutto il nostro sviluppo
futuro se non ripartiamo da qui
fondamentalmente lo sappiamo già il
percorso è già segnato eppure qualcuno
ha avuto appunto una visione diversa noi
oggi lavoriamo tutti i giorni per
applicare questa visione giorno dopo
giorno e lo facciamo attraverso una
serie di azioni di cui ma illustro
brevemente alcune il punto di partenza è
sempre la conoscenza la conoscenza la
divulgazione
avvicinarsi a quello che è l'oggetto di
cui stiamo parlando quindi partendo
innanzitutto dalla primissima infanzia
dai bambini e dei ragazzi è importante
passare il tempo in natura è importante
conoscere la natura è importante sapere
di cosa stiamo parlando
per arrivare poi una volta adulti a
continuare in qualche modo a informarsi
con costanza spendendo anche un po di
tempo nel ricercare quelle che sono le
fonti più più serie le fonti più
attendibili
partecipando quando si poi come si può
oggi esiste la citizen science che uno
strumento fantastico per la scienza per
arricchirsi e per uscire semplicemente
dai corridoi diciamo dell'accademia e
per i cittadini per sentirsi più parti
più partecipi di quello che è un
processo di costruzione della conoscenza
abbiamo poi un altro tema che riguarda
due attori principali quello della
lungimiranza da una parte riguarda i
governi abbiamo bisogno di governi di
decisione maker di politici che abbiano
voglia di prendere decisioni
passo dopo passo talvolta strappo dopo
strappo che spingano la normativa che
spingano i paesi che spingano i nostri
sistemi di governo nella direzione
giusta considerate che la normativa
comunque la legge è alla base di quello
che noi riusciamo a proteggere dal punto
di vista della natura quindi l'azione
dei governi dei policy makers rimane in
qualche modo fondamentale al tempo
stesso abbiamo bisogno di aziende
imprese business con visione
lungimirante persone che scelgono di
avere una visione che va al di là di
quello che è l'obbligo all'interno del
quale si muovono e cercano in qualche
modo di percorrere strade innovative
veramente con la volontà l'intenzione la
convinzione che in questo modo possono
contribuire a traghettare il nostro
sistema socio economico verso modello
diverso
abbiamo poi l'economia circolare la
quale richiede tutti e tre gli
ingredienti di cui abbiamo appena
parlato perché l'economia circolare
fondamentalmente poi meccanismo che
punta a chiudere il cerchio tutto quello
che viene messo in qualche modo con in
qualche già previsto come come ne
disponiamo così che non ci sia il
rilascio in natura e di tutto quello che
può essere inquinante non ci siano
sprechi ma questo richiede da una parte
cittadini appunto consapevole
informatiche quindi facciano un certo
tipo di scelte governi che come loro
leggi in qualche modo rendano possibile
quando proprio non rendano obbligatoria
questa strada e imprese che a
prescindere da tutto questo decidano di
investire credendoci in questa direzione
a volte prendendo anche strade
pionieristiche strade non sperimentate
state che non hanno un ritorno immediato
ma non ritorno sul medio e lungo termine
che è quello a cui stiamo guardando oggi
infine ultima ma non ultima la
tecnologia tecnologia circolare un
termine desueto diciamo che molti di voi
immagino gli staranno chiedendo a cosa
fare riferimento
ora la tecnologia oggi è uno dei
grandissimi protagonisti del nostro
mondo siamo in una fase in cui
sicuramente l'evoluzione tecnologica la
fa da padrone è tendenzialmente incrocio
alla conservazione tutto quello che
riguarda la tutela della natura quasi
per caso al momento quando l'immagine
vedete l'immagine di un bellissimo
progetto che abbiamo lanciato quest'anno
ad esempio che si chiama né sul guardian
e che permette la prevenzione del
bracconaggio e
delle azioni legali all'interno delle
aree protette tramite un sistema di
sensori che sono alimentati a pannelli
solari e che permettono il monitoraggio
in via diretta di tutto quello che
riguarda appunto le attività che si
svolgono nell'area protetta ma non può e
non è sufficiente che sia questo il modo
di applicare la tecnologia la tecnologia
enel.si tutto si può nutrire di natura
perché la biomimesi inca una disciplina
che esiste soprattutto diciamo ha
raggiunto una sua dignità pochissimi
anni è appunto la disciplina che
consente di unire mettere insieme e
tutto quello che viene dallo studio
degli organismi viventi con l'evoluzione
della tecnologia
la tecnologia arm moltissimo da imparare
dallo studio degli organismi viventi e
in secondo luogo c'è una tecnologia che
può nascere fin da subito già
finalizzata all equilibrio con la natura
alla conservazione della natura quindi
una tecnologia anche questa circolare
che parte dalla natura e tornò nella
natura
qual è quindi il punto è qualcosa cosa
in cosa consiste questo questa questa
strategia questo percorso questa visione
che noi possiamo e dobbiamo attuare in
qualche modo per invertire questa
accelerazione che il nostro malgrado
abbiamo preso che ci sta portando contro
muro al momento ma che non siamo
condannati a perseguire fondamentalmente
dobbiamo accettare una realtà è che è la
realtà del fatto che noi storicamente
come come specie animale siamo sempre
stati portati ad adattare l'ambiente
esterno a noi alle nostre necessità
abbiamo trasformato trasformato prima in
maniera minuscola quasi impercettibile
po in maniera sempre più importante nel
corso di secoli nel corso di millenni
l'ambiente circostante
siamo arrivati a un punto in cui non
possiamo farlo più siamo arrivati a un
punto in cui dobbiamo accettare che
dobbiamo essere noi ad adattare qualcosa
del nostro modo di vivere delle nostre
abitudini delle nostre convinzioni anche
allo spazio che abbiamo intorno a noi
quindi il tempo del cambiamento è
sicuramente arrivato la sfida è
sicuramente importante è una sfida che
riguarda accettare uno sforzo e qualche
piccolo cambiamento nella vita di oggi
per quello che poi la visione del futuro
piazze
[Applauso]